we are a territory with a with a
national personality
we need our independence i watch amish
gente case somos españoles y que el
portal FL espana spain is in the middle
of a political battle that threatens to
split the country the region of
Catalonia held a referendum to decide if
they wanted to become an independent
state and therefore separate from Spain
the Spanish Constitutional Court's rule
the referendum illegal and the central
government tried to stop it from
happening
they arrested government officials who
are planning on holding the boat
confiscated ballots and closed polling
stations undeterred the regional Catalan
government announced that voters could
print their ballots at home and vote at
any open polling station it didn't take
long for the situation to escalate
nearly 1,000 people were injured in the
violence five of them seriously as for
the results 90 percent of participants
voted to secede this would seem like
almost unanimous approval but less than
half of all eligible voters in Catalonia
turned out to vote based on the results
the Catalan government is threatening to
declare independence from Spain
unilaterally in response the Spanish
government is preparing an unprecedented
takeover of catalonia's regional powers
which will remove its leaders from
office so how did they get here
Spain is made up of 17 semi-autonomous
regions each with their own identity
some like Catalonia are distinct enough
that they have their own language as
well as culture cuisine and literature
Spain is a decentralized unified state
that means that autonomous regions like
Catalonia are governed according to the
National Constitution as well as laws
enacted independently by each regional
government but it wasn't always this way
from 1939 to 1975 Spain lived under a
fascist dictatorship Francisco Franco
eliminated Democratic liberties freedom
of the press and political opposition he
also crushed regional diversity around
the country to impose a single national
identity for Catalonia that meant
suppressing the Catalan language as well
as local traditions it was a big blow to
the Catalan culture when Franco died in
1975 Spain transitioned into a democracy
and the newly created Constitution
expanded autonomy in the regions
the Constitution allowed for a few
things Catalonia self-governance it
recognized Catalan is an official
language of Catalonia and was
specifically recognizing autonomy in the
regions that comprise Spain it also
cemented that Spain was indivisible as
Spain's democracy strengthened so did
Catalonia's pride then for the first
time since the Constitution was created
Catalans tried to expand their autonomy
the 2006 referendum called for many
things it called for a new economic
model for Catalonia to define Catalonia
as a nation and to privilege the Catalan
language over Spanish after four years
of legal battles the Constitutional
Court struck down some of the amendments
when the constitutional ruling was
announced 1 million Catalans went to the
streets of Barcelona where they carried
signs that read we are a nation we
decide
there are economic motivations for
independence to Catalonia is one of the
most prosperous regions in Spain it
takes up only 6% of the country but it
accounts for one-fifth of Spain's
economic output in 2016
nearly 21% of Spain's tax revenue came
from Catalonia we pay a lot of taxes
they taken them away they don't return
into
better infrastructures into into better
living conditions pro-independence
Catalans believe catalonia pays too much
money into the central government
compared to what it gets in return
catalonia like madrid and other richer
regions support the poorer parts of
Spain this sentiment grew during the
European economic crisis when a wave of
unemployment hit Spain but despite
growing support the majority of Catalans
don't want independence low-income
families are less likely to support
independence than those who are well-off
as our Catalans who live in cities
compared to those who live in rural
areas which brings us back to today
banks and multinationals have started to
move their headquarters out of Barcelona
to other Spanish regions Catalan
separatists have turned to Europe for
support but most European Union leaders
have cited with the central government
they have made it clear that an
independent Catalonia would have to
apply for EU membership a process that
would take years and while the fight on
Catalan independence will eventually be
settled it may take a long time for
Catalonia and Spain to return to
peaceful coexistence
you
[Applause]